vous avez un président fort variés un
petit peu vous interpréter une tranche
de vie
angélique nous avons ramené au camp dans
l'eau nombreux périples dans les usines
parisienne
ça s'intitule la chaîne g
krach rampant bingbing gut terminé
quilit-quilit permis ne craque pas
bim ares doing good terminé
quilit-quilit terminé crack entend mine
à hollywood terminé tu as passé la pause
a dit mme andrieux dimanche j'ai vu une
fille comme ça il encore qu'ils savaient
que les filles doit commencer ton truc
toi comment tu fais crée toujours comme
ça contre quoi revoir à lormes alors
voilà c'est facile alors match je
l'appelle gracq
elle arrive enfin au bar à tapas aille
en bouche un coin bing gens m'aident à
la maison au winch au fauteuil basculant
est terminée et toi comment cet autre
huit mois commence très très vite
commencé